the framework for me doing social brand
building and building businesses is
what's the brand stand for what's the
business objective the next thing we do
is we create 40 to 50 consumer
segmentations not three right 40 to 50
consumer segmentations 18 to 22 year old
males limbing in Bangladesh that are
into Esports 21 to 27 year old females
in Tokyo making 200 000 a year 40 to 45
year old moms in Malaysia who have an
affinity towards High fashion real
specific consumer cohorts with real
teeth okay next on that is called pack
platforms and culture like do you
actually understand what the platforms
are doing next which platforms are you
creating for you've now gone the whole
way down now it's we're going to pick
Instagram and Facebook and Twitter and
for me every brand that's in this room
should be on all of them
but this is back to allocation more to
their dollars go so they can't but they
should but they'd rather spend eight
million dollars on a TV spot
so you lay out the platforms then you go
to work so now you create a framework
now your creative and strategy team are
ready to work now you start posting
against
framework right you know what consumer
you're going after you know what you're
trying to achieve in business you know
how the platforms work so you know
Facebook reels is underpriced right now
you know that green screen headline
creative is over indexing on Tick Tock
you know so you start making now the
work really begins after you make you
have a person your strategy team called
the PCS a post creative strategist her
and his job is to look at all the
qualitative feedback you have your
analytics and media team look at the
Quant feedback and you start making your
machine smart like a half pregnant AI
the team gets smart through the work you
start looking at the proxies when you've
got a retail brand that sells in retail
stores you're running the media against
hold out clusters to prove that you're
actually driving incremental growth if
you have a DTC brand or an app it's a
piece of cake you're just looking at the
black and white data when the creative
goes viral or over indexes its Norm it
becomes the brief for more
efficient and effective work so now the
virality based on the consumer sentiment
and intent and truth becomes a proxy to
your brief not a strategist sitting in
an office going on Reddit for four hours
writing a brief
then you do that forever and ever and
ever
your cohorts are an accordion as you
start getting affirmation that
something's not working you actually
eliminate Malaysian moms 40 45 because
you aren't finding Affinity your
creative team hasn't hit the mark on the
flip side while marketing to Indonesia
Gamers 13 to 15 you realize it's
actually the female Gamers 13 to 15 that
are even more interested in the intent
and you create a new cohort to go there
to double down on the truth of the
consumer not the audacity of the board
group
thank you
[Music]